معنا منها طايا عبد الله الطاي مسؤول
الدبلوماسيه الانسانيه في هيئه الاغاثه
الانسانيه التركيه سيد عبد الله يوما بعد
يوم كيف تطورون
ادائكم فيما يتعلق ونتكلم بدايه التكفل
بالجرحى ومن يدخلون المستشفيات ويحتاجون
الى ربما عمليات المتقدمه لا تتوفر في
المناطق المنكوبه
مساء الخير
مساء الخير لكم جميعا في البدايه اود ان
اقول ان عمليات البحث ما زالت مستمره
رغم توقفها في بعض الاماكن هذا ما يعني ان
هناك مزيد من الجرحى او مما يحتاجون الى
عنايه في الحقيقه هناك
تقييم اولي للحاله اول ما تفرض ليس كل
حاله تذهب الى نفس المكان بعد التقييم
الاولي تنقل الحاله بحسب منطقتها هناك
حالات ممكن ان تنقل الى مشاكل قريبه وهناك
حالات تنقل مباشره
بالطائرات الى
اسطنبول او انقره لذلك لا يتم التعامل مع
كل الحالات على نفس
المبدا طيب
لنتكلم عنها طاي وذكرت بان ما زالت عمليات
البحث مستمره شاهدنا في الساعتين
الماضيتين حاله هذه العائله سبع افراد تم
استخراج اثنين من هذه العائله وبالتالي ما
المسار الذي يتم عند حصول نبا سارك هذا
يعني انا لا استطيع ان اعكس لك كم الفرحه
عندما نسمع ان هناك عائله خرجت انا كنت
شاهد على خروج احد الاحياء في هاتاي
في الحقيقه نحن الان في وقت المعجزه هذا
الوقت هو نسميه وقت المعجزه الان عندما
يخرج احياء فهذا يعني ان هناك معجزات
تتحقق لان بالارقام
وقياسا على ما سمعناه ان الامم المتحده
ربما اعلنت توقف العمليات او انه لن يكون
هناك احياء اليوم عندنا حالتان حقيقيتان
الاولى في مراش والثانيه في هاتاي ونحن
لدينا تجربه في هذا الموضوع سيدي كما قلت
سابقا اشرت في لقاء اخر في هايتي نحن في
اليوم الرابع عشر استطعنا ان نخرج احياء
لذلك لا يمكن ان نتوقف الا بعد ان نجري
المسحه الكامل على كل المناطق
منها طه عبد الله الطاي مسؤوله دبلوماسيه
الانسانيه في هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه
التركيه شكرا جزيلا لك